so thank you thank you for the
invitation
this is an application area at all
obviously so let me
tell you about the application area is
interested in
computational Game Theory
some tasting game three what we are
doing is we are designing
algorithms uh
that takes this input a description of a
game and uh outputs a solution to that
game
and in Game Theory we have several
solution Concepts so
tuning
many different things depending on on
the game
typical examin is the value of the game
and as equilibrium things like that
and you'll see see exactly one example
in this talk
I should say also that I'm from the
from the algorithms community so I mean
particularly interested in in designing
algorithms that
it deals with an entire class of games
and it's also all of them and I'm
interested in the worst case complexity
of these algorithms so
I'm more interested in Indian home
efforts in particular instances of um of
games
okay
um I'm going to talk about how to apply
wheel algebraic geometry to um to this
area
and the fact that you can do so is not
it's not
super surprising
um
I don't know how how well this community
is a way of it both actually that's a
long and distinguished history of
applying you know debate geometry in
what it would call Pure Game Theory
non-computational
and um
I'm not going to give a survey of that
but uh
so here's some some Classics uh in the
theory of stochastic games which is
actually also
the cast will be looking at a little
later
and this line of development is uh
particularly interesting I think because
El debate geometries really
I mean the main engine
Behind These results
and so these are not sort of French
French papers in particular
this is famous people by merchants and
neyman uh
approved fundamentally so about
stochastic games that was open for 20
years
uh until they
finally proved in 1981 namely the
existence of value of a value of an old
discounted stochastic game this was a
major breakthrough uh and uh the key
ingredient was was really debate
geometry
that's good of course
um
all these perhaps
also good is that
these papers don't use any particularly
Advanced tools from from you at the bay
geometry so um
uh so typically uh and this is potato
goes for this basically we saw the the
real course is actually the tasky 25
principle and not much else the rest is
uh just hard work and
any sense of Elementary argument put on
put on top of it but I think it's safe
to say that the core is
the transfer principle
and of course this
uh
makes you wonder if you can get further
with the sharper tools then nearly stuff
like the transfer principle and this is
uh the Miss it's a slogan of this talk
that
in particular in the computational
setting I'm interested in algorithms for
for solving these games and finer tools
are very adventurous and I'm going to
use tools from this monograph at the
previous speaker also
showed you on the slide
um
I should say though that I mean even
though I'm you know focused on the
commutational setting it's also true
that you can you can take these finer
tools you can go back to
things like this and there's some nice
low hanging fruit there and I've been
plugging some of them some of that food
recently but I think there's more more
stuff to be done
and I also want to say that I'm very
much a consumer I feel a little debate
geometry I don't know anything beyond
what's in this this very nice book uh
and I don't know anything in the book
and I think in the future will be nice
to a bit more back and forth between um
the two areas not just Reliant
off-the-shelf tools that that I'm going
to rely on and I hope
to talk to some of you about about this
already I'm talking to to a few of you
so it's very nice to be here
okay
um
so yeah we've been doing this in a
number of papers but uh I'll just have
time to show you one example
and that I don't maybe you know someone
algorithms person I'm interested in uh
worst case complexity analysis of
algorithms uh so you may not may or may
not be interested in in this particular
area so you can view it as an example of
of things one can do sort of
non-trivially with Lila debate geometry
so it's uh so the computational problem
uh I'm looking at is Computing the value
of a concurrent visibility game so if
you know Game Theory value suggest that
we're in a two-player sales some case
which we are
also what what kind of game this is in a
slide and there's a particular classical
algorithm called strategy situation that
essentially solves this this problem uh
but it was open how to do a worst case
the worst case complexity of the
algorithm was opened and we essentially
cracked that using using real estate
geometry
uh what what makes it interesting a
little interesting I think is that the
algorithm itself does not rely on the
debate geometry so you can explain it to
people who never heard about this this
topic and the algorithm is uh
well it's a variant of an algorithm that
goes back to to the to the 40s and the
ol community so you can certainly
understand the eyewitness also it's
correctness without uh Villa debate
geometry
and even though I'm going to use
um
tools from the yellow book and even
though I'm interested in algorithms I'm
not going to use algorithms from them
from the yellow book so in sergata stock
Associated distinction I'm going to use
qualitative information from
from his his book but not not the IQ
algorithm so the algorithms Play No role
in this particular algorithm so I'm just
using the quantitative information to
understand what this algorithm algorithm
does and how fast how fast it is
okay so that's the example and I'll show
you actually all the details of this
example that's my ambition and I think
you can do it in the remaining 10
minutes oh 14 minutes
okay
um okay so actually I'm going to use one
one
fear Him from the from the book and to
get the bound I want I can't afford
Quantified elimination so this is a
ethereum called
the sounding film I think in the
uh in in the monograph uh and I can
listen from the online edition not the
not the paper Edition so I violated all
copyright constraints and just put it on
on my slides here I hope so daughter
doesn't mind
uh I don't know if you can you can pass
this uh something very fast I know sort
of an abbreviated
version here so if you have a uh
set of polynomial equations and
inequalities
um so uh
sign condition the flat sign condition
can be realized
by some some point
we'll we'll
repeat in space then it's realized by a
point of low algebraic complexity so
this this pointer is a universe
representation
uh uh where the involved polynomials
have have sort of low degree and also uh
sort of small coefficient size
height as a this
quantity was was called in a talk
yesterday
okay so this is uh oops uh the essence
of the
of the engine I'm going to use and I'm
going to use it in this way so so what
uh
sales is actually an algorithm that
produces
a point uh satisfying a sign condition
and then
now we can expect what the algorithm
does and then it will have this property
but I'm just going to use
it in in you know as a constructive
proof that this this point exists I'm
not going to use the algorithm that
computes the point at all
which also means that if you you you
want to optimize a bit then then this
can be optimized a bit because then you
can avoid one of the deformations used
to prove the theorem which is also
pointed out in the in the book
but I'll come back to
that at the end of The Talk
okay so that's that's the office of
fair amount of use so what's the
algorithm are analyze so it's an
algorithm solving what is known a
concurrent visibility game
it's sort of easy to explain what those
games are he's a two-player sales some
games of a certain kind
so
they play between two players uh
one called the role player and one
called the column player
uh and
the game has a number of positions you
can think of it as a board game at any
point in time there's a current position
I'll mark that with the with the people
and
so it's a game of proportioning posting
interests so the objective of the role
player is to make this Pebble uh what
happened to
make these people reach the goal
procession
and the objective of the column player
the other player is to prevent the
people from from using the gold position
so these are called role players and
column players because each position of
the game is given by a matrix
still probably no Matrix Games so these
are special matrices these are not
matrices containing payouts but their
matrices containing pointers to other
positions and actually all interest in
all of these Matrix is container pointed
to some other position it could be
itself but only do some of them to mess
up the picture so if you think of you
know there's also some some pointer here
Etc
okay so how is the game played uh so
it's played as follows so there's a
current position and then as in the case
of a matrix game the the role player
chooses a role and the column player
simultaneously chooses a column so so
two choices uh uh you know they're
hidden from from each other so second
thing if it is they do it simultaneously
so so the column player to do this
without knowing what the role player did
uh and then maybe you can guess what
happens and the the two actions here
Define an entry of the Matrix and what
we do is we let the people move along
that
that uh you know corresponding Arrow the
outgoing Arrow from that that entry now
we are in a new new position of the game
and then we just do the same thing again
the Real Player Two to zero and
simultaneously the column player two is
a column and then the people moves again
now it's here and uh this might get
boring so let's pretend now this happens
and then
the people actually reach the goal
positions and this play in this case the
role player won won the game
uh so that's that's that's it so so
concurrent usability game is given by
such a finite structure
uh and how do we play it well
um
that's one thing that shouldn't surprise
you is that you want to play this game
well you have to use randomized
strategies uh because you're dealing
with a game of imperfect information so
it's like a it's like a matrix game with
payoffs but it's more more
commentatorial and more complicated
actually as we will see
okay
uh so what's what's the fundamental
theorem about these games so it's a game
of opposing interest so we should expect
some kind of min max film to be the
fundamental theorem and indeed that's
the case
uh which is the film by Everett uh 1957.
one of the founding papers of stochastic
games
and you showed that these games have
values more precise you're going to sign
to each position of the game and value
and that value is a probability
and it's the uh it's the optimal winning
probability of the role player the
probability that he can make the Pebble
Beach goal
and it's a value in the sense that both
players agree that this is the uh
the value so so uh uh the
low pair has strategies that will
uh yeah
well that's a technicality but if it was
a Max you would have a strategy that
would guarantee this value and the the
column play as a strategy that
guarantees that uh the winning
probabilities of all player will not
exceed this this value
so you get some kind of min max
statement and the only thing that makes
it different from the min max statement
from Matrix Games which
any of you probably know is they have a
super instead of MX which means that the
actually only approximate the attained
this optimal probability so we can get
as close as he wants in general but
there are cases where you cannot not
achieve it exactly
um
okay some other dues to get out of the
statement here so notice a bit by
stationary here and what that means is
that the good strategies we're looking
for are so-called statinary strategies
meaning that uh
when you want to play this game well you
don't have to remember how you got to a
particular position all you have to do
is to choose some probability
distribution uh on the accents of the
position and and play that distribution
and then uh that's your ID
okay so what we want to do when we solve
the games is to compute a solid for the
role players what I want to do for
particular position parameters to to
find a strategy here that uh
uh you know uh gets gets close within
the the Precision to this this optimal
probability
good
new optimal strategy for them for the
role player
and that's a classical algorithm that
essentially solves this problem is you
at least the the the the file that this
algorithm is due to Howard was designed
for for Markov decision processes so I
like to call it Howard's algorithm
because it's very general and this is
just one of the uh
the cases in which it applies and here's
his the algorithm for the case of
concurrent readability gains and it's
actually non-trivial to uh to make sure
it's correct in this case so so this was
so the adaptation to concurrent
visibility games was done independently
in this paper by Charlie Del file and
hensinger in this paper by by one of the
people in the room which it is
so I guess very briefly because I'm
running out of time already tell you
what the algorithm does you can see it
doesn't rely geometry so it's an
iteration so you start with an with a
laboratory strategy and it's assumed for
ingredients it's a uniform distribution
uh at each position this is a strategy
for the
for the role player so you freeze
that strategy in a sense I assume the
role player will play this and then you
have a one player game okay so I have a
markup decision process we can you can
solve two optimality this is what I do
here so now I have two strategies one
for the role playing one for the column
player
you know a strategy profile is just a
Markov process so I can just compute the
probability that I'd end up in the gold
position for meets each position of the
game
uh uh and then what I'll do is something
clever now I have a number assigned to
each each position
now all these matrices so the matrices
now have pointers that point to numbers
so we place the pointers with the
numbers they point to and then I saw the
all the matrices as ordinary Matrix
Games and I think if I get a bigger
value of that Matrix Game than the
current position and if I do that then I
switch the strategy in that position to
an optimal strategy of the Matrix gain
uh and if you know the
uh algorithm for for um
for Markov decision processes this
device by Howard you will see that this
is an actual thing to do here and I just
now I have a new new fixed strategy and
then I'll just repeat this this Loop
here forever
oh until I'm sort of
heavy because what the property is that
these valuations these numbers survive
on the vertices rightfully converge to
the real values of the game and also the
strategies that compute along the way
which you can see from the pseudocode
will guarantee these valuations in other
words if I run this uh algorithm long
enough I'll get a strategy that
guarantees the optimal values within
Epsilon for the role player for
arbitrary small Epsilon okay
this was proved in the two papers I'm
interested okay
so what we want to analyze is this what
is the number of iterations required to
guarantee a good good approximation
and this this is the film we we showed
it took a long time to show this because
I don't think you would expect to I mean
I don't know how to prove this without
using a little bit geometry and I think
it's surprising because
excessive anything to do with the
degrees of uh of debate numbers
Etc but you can prove this for all games
for in positions the name actions for
each player needs positions uh this
number one divided by f stand to the end
to the some constant times
and the two parameters in this number of
positions and then
is the dimension of the of the matrices
let's just assume they all have the same
dimension
okay
um okay so I'll you know I can have two
minutes to actually do the proof so
instead of three step proof then two
first steps of sort of more game
theoretic than than either break so I'll
do it quickly so what what we do and
this is already done in the paper that
showed correctness of um
of the algorithm we can relate the
valuations computed by the variation
computer by another iteration called
value iteration which is in a sense less
useful because it doesn't produce a
strategy it only produces approximations
to the values but it means that in order
to to show that uh these these
evaluations converge to these values
quick I only have to consider these
valuations and value iteration has a
natural Game Theory interpretation uh
what you do in value tradition is you
compute the value of a time-bounded gain
you assume that the role player has to
win the game within a certain time bound
and you compute the value of of that
finite game which you can do by
backwards induction uh well-known
concept from from Game Theory values of
this time about t that's what this
situation does
okay so I will not have time to
explain further but this means that uh
we can sort of reduce the question to a
game for the question in order to prove
that the convergence is fast you have to
up about the difference in value between
the time bounded game and the original
version of the game the game where
there's no no time bound on the time
necessary to win to win the game and so
inside you can sort of do that uh in an
inventory way we're considering a
parameter of the strategies called
patience so we have a particular
strategy uh
station is ready for playing the game I
Define his patience as
one divided by the smallest non-zero
probability used so you have to use very
very small probabilities in my in my
game then in my in my play in my
strategy then the patience will be will
be higher
and intuitively if you can win a game
without being very patient then there's
only a small difference in difference in
value between the time value than the
infinite version and actually you can
prove that as a limit which has an
elementary proof okay and now the new
ladybug geometry so now essentially what
you if you you know
in order to show that straight iteration
is uh is fast in convergence I only have
to show that you know each of these
games have a near Optimum strategy with
low patience and in order to do that I
this is now sort of meta mathematical
and I'll look at average proof that
these games have value have a value
and when you chose this sort of defines
two two sets C1 and C2 uh C1 is
essentially the uh
the vectors where if I apply value
duration operator once and I get
something bigger and C2 is defined uh
you know analogously and the the value
Vector uh this is a unique intersection
between the closure of these two sets
and
there's something in in you know one of
these sets which is close to this uh uh
you know this this unique big Vector
then I can from that compute any optimal
strategy that's what the film says but
it's an advantage to only work on these
uh C1 and C2 sets because defined on a
lower dimensional space which is good
for me
in order to formalize what's on the
previous I'd have to solve linear
programs that seems to involve quantify
elimination but it doesn't have to
because I'm going to add as many
constraints as I want without being
penalized by by the same thing theorem
so I'll do some basis enumeration and
derive a quantifier free
formula for this statement namely that I
have a pair of vectors one in C1 and one
and C2 and they're they're dealing
distances is uh is close
and so take that uh apply the sampling
uh film from uh from the nice book by
salgata and now I get
um you know I get a bound on the other
big degree and coefficient size of
universitation of uh of this this
element in C1 that I'm I'm looking for
and I'll do the computation uh and and
the reason I do it this way is that I
mean I I do this for the only
invariables uh but now I've reintroduced
the variables of the strategies by by
doing this computation that everyone
suggests I do and you know that I can do
that keeping this Innovative
representation under control and now
just apply a cushy bounce and I get a
bound on the size of the numbers I'm
looking at uh so this gives me the
Abundant patience I want and then I get
my main film as a result that's the
entire entire proof and I'm almost out
of time uh I want to point out this is
tight uh you can prove that maybe the
band looks sort of horrible it stop the
exponential light so it's tight here's
the game that shows it's tight it's a
natural game uh but so so so I know that
this is a lower bound one divided by 10
to the m to the big n minus little over
n so in other words the lower bound I
have the constant in the the upper
exponent is one
what is a a constant here uh I mean the
previous speaker I mean Medicare it's
very interesting what what big ocean
exponents are in this exponent is one
higher up in his exponent so of course
we want to know uh I don't quite know
because it's it's the same Bagel as this
big over here of course you can go
through the proof and then you'll get
some expression but I understand why uh
because the expression sort of becomes
nasty now it's not a problem to make an
expression but you know the trade-off
between our symbol you want and how
accurate you want it and it's sort of I
understand understand why they work with
Big O but on the other hand it would
also be nice to know what this figure is
so I think it's more than 10 but this
one 100. uh as you can see I mean there
are many examples that's application so
I'm particularly also interested in if
you know if people in the room have
worked on uh sort of fine-tuned and
optimized versions of this this same
thing film and if they have and have
published and then send me a link and
I'll be interested so thank you
foreign